sharon what is going on how are we doing
i actually um
had coveted starting on christmas day
and i'm still recovering merry christmas
right
i know and what a way to start the new
year um
but yeah so i actually uh you know just
went through like
like on a scale of 1 to 10 it was
literally a 12 like that's how bad it
was
and i never get sick but i'm just like
mentally and physically just so
exhausted
um because it was just so draining and
you know just being stuck in a room the
whole for two weeks
and you know you have you have all these
goals in mind like
you start you want to start the new year
with all these goals and you have plans
and
i feel like everything got kind of put
on hold so like
just kind of asking what your opinion is
like what you think how do i how could i
get myself like back on track just to
get back to kind of normal almost like
doctor
yeah man you just gave me like 10
different shows worth of material
just here all right so number one um
you didn't slightly get derailed your
whole 2021
got blown up before it started right
you're that kid
i don't know if you you weren't in cub
scouts but they had like the pinewood
derby where they
make these fancy cars and they all get
in a line on these
ramp and they let them go yours is the
one kid that got stuck
right when they dropped it and all the
other kids went down and looked all
smooth and pretty
and yours just your car sucked it just
got stuck there right
it went nowhere yeah and so there's
number one you gotta be honest about
what happened
you got blowed up before you even got to
go up i'm gonna
i'm gonna trademark that that's probably
the smartest rap kind of thing i said
today
you got blowed up before you got to go
up um number two
how honest do you want me to be with you
because i you
you sharon sound like a really kind
person like a lovely human
and i can play high level or i can be
super
blunt and jocko willenick with you i can
just be direct which one
i i would like for you to be as honest
as possible
i mean because it's just because like
i'm a very like social person and
and i've i've been out of work since
then i'm a flight attendant so it's just
it's just been so hard because i've been
in my bubble this whole time yeah just
getting out you know even
socializing i got to learn to it's just
been
weird i just feel like i'm in a weird
place in life right now and
yes yes yes just exhausted okay so
here's i'm gonna walk you through real
fast everything in a nutshell and i want
you to
just hold your breath while i do it okay
okay
ready i'm ready almost a year
we'll say nine to ten months of varying
stories between if you get this you're
going to be dead it's not a big deal
what's going to happen
and you're a flight attendant so am i
going to get laid off am i going to keep
my job what are we going to do
oh i've got to be on this plane they're
making me fly with all these people
we're all going to get sick we're all
going to die
oh my gosh and i love my friend but well
i kissed that boy he's probably got it
he's probably going to die
every sniffle for the last nine months
um
you thought ah this is it this is death
right
and then yeah i want to hang out with
people it's not that big a deal
we're in atlanta it's not even in the
south so they say so we're all good in
atlanta
and then it's you get it on
freaking christmas right and then you
start thinking backwards
to all the people i was around did i
hurt somebody else because that's the
other thing right it's not only
i i might have it and be hurting other
people not even mean to but someone else
is gonna get sick and die because of me
and
and then it goes over and over and i
blew up my family's christmas plans and
my friends plans and what about 2021 i
got this new journal with all these
freaking ribbons in it that was going to
help me on my day planner journal and
month and goals and
and it all just blows up and you are
super super sick
all by yourself in a bed on christmas
day
and so there's one word for that and
it's just called trauma
okay and there's so many
influencers on the instagrams being like
dude i had it for 24 hours it was no big
deal or there's newscasters being like
everyone should die right the reality is
for some people it's not a big deal and
for others it is the scariest
terrifying thing i've got friends at
work i've got friends in my family i've
got
i've got friends of my family i got
family members i've had people who have
had it not that bad i've had people that
were
terrified right it is what it is it was
definitely scary
you got real right there you go and you
probably like my idiot self you probably
went to the internet to see what i could
do and what would happen and then they
just really fan the flame of joy right
because what else are you gonna do when
you're stuck in a room by yourself
right and i never go ahead go ahead
um i'm never go and that's another thing
like i never get sick so that's why
i think it like really hit me hard
because like i
actually had to go to the doctor twice
and i was so
sick like i i didn't think i honestly
did not think i was going to make it
because my breathing was so bad
and like it just hit me like oh my gosh
this is real
and then you start thinking oh i don't
ever get sick but i did this time i'm
going to be one of the ones and
right so all i have to say is your brain
is trying to do
the best it can to take care of you
and your year got blown up at the end
and at the beginning
the one the one holiday that you've had
since you were a little girl that
everyone just goes ah
that got blown up your work got blown up
your health got blown up
everything just blew up and so what i
want you to do and this is gonna sound
ridiculous
just go with me on it okay i want you to
hold some sort of miniature funeral
for what was gonna be okay and you can
be as funny about this you can get a
glass of wine get some friends on zoom
and y'all can be silly about it or you
can be teary and weepy about it okay
but i want you just to be honest about i
want you to have a moment
a ceremony a a moment of just checking
and pause where you're going to grieve
what just happened because it sucks
right yeah and it's not just that you
got coven got
really really sick it's all of it all
the scary all of the year it all
culminated and it all just goes
boom right there on your body right and
then
you had to sit for two weeks alone sick
alone there's nothing worse than being
alone there's nothing worse than being
sick alone
right with just screens and sleep and
screens and a doctor and then almost
death and then right so it's just on and
on
and then you have to let this fantasy of
what 2021 was gonna be go
and then i'm gonna give you some joy
okay
okay there is a wonderful saying by the
the great
um they're the great meditating gurus
but that every breath is a chance to
start over
right every breath is a chance to start
over and so i don't want to
undermine what just happened it's a big
deal and your body's
wrecked because of it and that means
your heart and your soul and your
spirit's wrecked of it
hold the funeral acknowledge what was
acknowledge what blew up in your face
and then say it's tuesday january
whatever
i'm starting today right
now i'm gonna start 2021 however late we
are and hey
after what happened the last few weeks
with the the all the stupid stuff going
on in the country with politics and all
that
why not start late right that's
true so good you're beating the system
here so way to go
so you now have a level of empathy
for the scared people that you're going
to be walking up and down the aisle with
on your in your work you're going to
have a new level of empathy for folks
that you work with who haven't got it
yet who are terrified they're going to
get it
you have a new level of empathy of what
it's like to be just freaking alone
you have a new level of empathy for what
um getting sick
looks like the difference between media
coverage right what's real and what's
not
you now have an insight to that you
didn't have before would you want it did
you want to experience that no but you
have it now
right and that is a firm
beautiful foundation of empathy love
compassion
and now there's no stopping me now you
had it now you had it now it's on 2021
right now sharon from atlanta game on
sister
i'm gonna go get it yeah right yeah and
now you can do whatever you want
and you can i love yeah i actually that
just you just picture like i just
pictured like a whole
sunshine after you said that that's what
it is i didn't even look at it that way
like you know yeah definitely because
there's other people that are probably
there are going through especially after
holidays
okay don't do that okay share it share
it don't do that
don't compare your situation to somebody
else well at least i didn't have that
right don't do that your grief is your
grief is your grief you get to own it it
sucked it was
if you got covered for 48 hours and you
just had weird weird weird boogers
right and rocket diarrhea and that's it
and you have a friend who went to the
hospital and she was put on a ventilator
for four days before she got to come
home
both of you have a right to your hurt
okay
don't minimize it don't minimize it and
don't be like well you're right other
people
in other countries have food don't do
that it what that's why i want you to
hold a ceremony for what happened to you
okay okay hold it it was what it was
and then yes the sun comes up
and it may not come up on the landscape
we wanted it may not come up in the home
that we wanted it may not come up in the
in the at the school we wanted to be at
it may not come up with the guy that we
thought we were going to be whatever the
thing is
but the sun always comes up it always
comes up
and then we go back to what the ancient
meditators would say is
every breath has a chance to start over
and i've been guilty guilty of like man
it's
it's may i've blown this year i can't
wait till till new year's right i'm
going to start over new year's that's so
stupid i blew a whole year man
so all you lost was three weeks that's
man you are in it
to win it by the way can i um
sharon i wanna thank you for that call
here's what i want you to do after your
funeral i want you to shoot me a note
back and i'm gonna read what your note
is
after you have this miniature funeral
again it can be funny it can be serious
i want you to let that go the fantasy of
2021 is going to be pop rocks and
fireworks and flowers and it's not it
sucked i got covered i was stuck in bed
i almost died
but now the sun's coming up and what are
we going to make of it right and then i
want to hear what you're going to do i
want to hear what you're going to write
down here's the person i'm going to be
in 2021
more empathetic more loving more looking
people in the eye and saying i see you
for the first time that's going to be
awesome and then here's
man this gets me a little bit ranty and
i won't because i want to wrap the show
up here
but you guys i talk a lot about um
you got to match your pictures with
words right we often use the same words
and we mean different things
covet is a great example about how
different
disciplines use the same words
and then they run off into the woods
with totally different meanings
if you guys remember back in february or
march of last year when this thing
started making its way around the world
um i was in manhattan when they closed
broadway i was on broadway with my
friend ken coleman we were walking down
broadway when they walked out and said
broadway's canceled
and we both looked at each other like
that sound super great
and they said canceled until further
notice and
no one had ever heard of anything like
that ever happening so we were downtown
new york when this thing started
when it became started falling like a
bunch of dominoes
and there were some modeling experts
some epidemiologists and modeling folks
who
made some predictions early on at
university science labs
and they in again labs some of you guys
think of labs with beakers
some labs have people in them some labs
have computers in them so i'm using the
word liberty liberally here
um liberally is that that's right yeah
yeah
um and they said hey we think 13 14
million people are going to die or
whatever
wild number it was so here's the thing
in science when they say
i think this for scientists that means
game on
because the whole practice of science is
based on iron sharpens iron peer review
oh yeah
i am going to reject your null
hypothesis i'm going to go try to find
out where you're wrong i'm going to look
in the gap look in the gap look in the
gap
and then shortly a few weeks later it
had been revised down
we think 7 million people so those folks
took those new models new information
new data and they're making new models
and new models and they're
they're reducing reducing they're
getting better and better and better
so science has a built-in mechanism when
it's honest with itself
for i think this here's my hypothesis
here's what i think is going to happen
and then all other scientists in that
area in that field or in peripheral
fields
they go to war dude they it is on and
it's this beautiful
refining process to try to get to truth
right but you know who doesn't have a
refining process politicians in the
media
because they all walked out the next day
and said 14 million people are gonna die
and they have no ability because of ego
because of narrow-minded thinking
short-term thinking they have no way to
go back and say
oh you know what the best information we
had last week was 14 million people
the latest data tells us it's going to
be 10 million that's a great news
everybody we're going to keep
learning the best we can doing what we
have in our pockets right now but
the number's getting smaller it's still
way way way way way too big but
they can't do that they have to look at
each other and start saying well you
lied well you lied well you're stupid
science is dumb
and it's this this crosstalk that
happens in marriages it happens in
families it happens in businesses
happens in schools
where people are using the same language
and they're using it to mean different
things
god almighty if politicians could say
these magic words i'm sorry i learned
new information
i'm changing i'm changing what i said
the other day and i'm going this way and
if we all
cheered those people you know why
because that's wisdom
the ability to say oh dude i got new
info i got new info
and now i'm wiser and i'm going to
restate something that i said earlier
i'm going to say something differently i
changed my mind and we all cheered for
them
ah can you imagine that if the media was
able to come out on a tuesday after
making a big report on monday and be
like hey we got that one wrong
whoopsie do are bad we got new
information we screwed that up
here's the new thing oh we didn't screw
it up we just tried our best with what
we had
and we got we got new information
all i had to say is say the words i'm
sorry be people of wisdom be people that
said man i got new info